Thank You comrades I want to say I'm
next I want to tell you it's nice to be
here at the Academy Awards I just
returned from Moscow they didn't
recognize me there either
now but this is nicest group of filthy
capitalists I've ever seen it's nice to
be back here at least here they allow
the losers to stay in town
but what a reception what a reception I
got in Moscow people told me you had
there hadn't been anything like it since
Napoleon arrived and I must say they
gave us wonderful treatment they put us
in a very modern hotel they have TV in
every room only it watches you
Kari grant was in Russia just before us
he lives dangerously he walked into a
restaurant order Deutsch ders
Rockefeller but this is a great night
for Hollywood the Oscar Derby again what
suspense everyone's got their fingers
crossed it's like the countdown at Cape
Canaveral and it's catching I was
nervous as a Russian scientist dog I
haven't been able to appear at the last
few Academy Awards because of
conflicting sponsors but tonight the
conflict is gone and so are the sponsors
just imagine all this expensive talent
assembled by the movie industry and
giving away free to television in fact
they've even closed most of the movie
theaters to make sure you stay home it
just goes to prove that this industry
isn't frightening it's off its rocker
never before in history as so many stars
been on one show someone should suddenly
explode a bomb and blow up every big
star in this theater I still wouldn't
get in the war so put it in the bucket
of water Charlie what do you know all of
America has been watching this show and
it's been pretty confusing after almost
an hour and a quarter they still don't
know what they're supposed to run down
with the corner grocery and buy
one guy in Utah has been watching Lana
and Kim and he just phoned us he knows
what he wants but he doesn't know where
to send the box tops
but the popularity of this program
tonight on television proves what I've
always said
actors may yet replace the horse I'd
like to replace that joke now we have
though the last time I did this show I
was the sole emcee tonight therefore MCS
ahead of me
I knew unemployment was widespread but I
didn't think it was this bad
I was very interested in who was gonna
win the award for Best Actor tonight so
I checked with Price Waterhouse but
they're a very reputable firm so they
sent my check back now I haven't won an
award in 15 years and I've been trying
very hard and I just want to say to my
producers directors and cameramen but I
could never have done it alone you all
helped
I don't even know if I'm still in show
business I haven't received a memo from
David Selznick today though I've never
really wanted an Oscar although I guess
they are reassuring to an actor who
doesn't know how great he really is at
least that's what Peter Potter told me
but remember it's not whether you win or
lose it's how you play the game that's
what I say and I'll keep on saying until
my psychiatrist tells me I can stop our
industry can be proud of the list of
nominees this year it's been read into
the record at the UN I won't say there
are many foreign names on the list but
this year the Academy switched from
Price Waterhouse to Berlitz sessue
hayakawa Miyoshi amici Vittorio De Sica
Anna Munn Yanni
I think we're carrying this foreign aid
too far now they shot sayonara in Japan
in the bridge on the river kwai in
Malaya and the only place they had any
trouble the natives when they shot
Peyton Place in Massachusetts but ladies
and gentlemen right now I would like to
introduce two of our great actors to our
most popular motion picture stars here
in Hollywood for the best writing of a
motion picture here is Doris Day and
Clark Gable right here
to present the riding awards tonight
thank you Bob I know from experience
that writers are the hardest workers in
Hollywood yeah if they'd worked a little
harder Clark I wouldn't have to go to
Moscow to get last
are you ready yes I think so
the nominees for best written screenplay
based on material from another medium
are Pierre Boulle the bridge on the
river kwai John Lehman and John Huston
for heaven knows mr. Allison
John Michael Hayes Peyton Place Paul
Osburn say you know
Reginald rose 12 Angry Men you open the
doors all right Pierre Boulle the Bridge
on the River Kwai
you know that
my boss the late mr. Harry Cohen was
very very proud of this film bridge on
the river kwai as all of us at Columbia
are and I am very honored and very happy
to accept this work Pierre Boulle thank
you
and now for the best story in screenplay
written especially for the screen the
nominees are George well for designing
woman Leonard Gersh for funny face man
of a thousand faces story by ralph
wheelwright and screenplay by r-right
Campbell Ivan Gough and Ben Roberts the
Ken Starr story by Barney Slater and Joe
King screenplay by Dudley nickel vigil
oh nice story by Federico Fellini any of
Lozano and Tulio Fanelli screenplay by
Federico Fellini and NGO Lozano
it's all yours designing woman George
well
the suggestion for the screenplay
designing woman came from one of our
industry's most wonderful designing
women Helen Rose